every week for the last 12 years
villages from Berlin have demonstrated
against Israel's occupation and the
construction of settlements in the West
Bank but they're also angry about Donald
Trump who they believe is aligning
himself with the Israeli right-wing
protests here was pretty small about
20-25 general traders some of them
Palestinian many of international
activists we've started peaceful enough
but some of the Palestinian youth have
been hurling rocks over the separation
barrier and the Israeli soldiers have
responded with rounds of teargas and
sponge bullets many Palestinians fear
the new American leader may upend
decades of US policy destroying their
chance of an independent state if he
continued has promised for this it will
be I think another Intifada in Palestine
it will be third intifada and big
Intifada because no one except the
killing of the dream of the Palestinian
we took a drive deeper into the West
Bank to visit an illegal Israeli outpost
to get a different perspective despite
the recent UN resolution condemning them
the building work continues on land that
would be part of a Palestinian nation in
a two-state solution
Shmuel Barak who hopes to finish his
house by the end of the year tells me
he's excited about Donald Trump
it's the settlement you think that the
Jewish people have to be here and if
it's over this this this those this land
with will support Israel to be stronger
and to and to I think I will do it
because it is interesting that they will
be strong the u.s. position has always
been that these settlements built on
land captured by Israel in the 1967
six-day war are an obstacle to peace
Israel - nice that and in Trump when he
settlers see an opportunity to expand it
was always time to annex it's also now
time to annex if it's tactically a good
in a tram period probably it's better
it's pretty of course better than Obama
let's try solving the israel-palestine
conflict has eluded the world's leaders
for years Donald Trump Bois says it's
the ultimate deal but one of his pledges
is to move the US Embassy from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem bucking international norms
Israel and the Palestinians both lay
claim to the city or part of it as their
capital at the beers eight university
near Ramallah students are nervous about
the next four years he's a bad person
he sports Israelis people and he's
supposed to you know like houses for
Jewish people but it's time I think it's
gonna be full of tension it's gonna be a
lot of tension in the area especially if
he does move Trump moves the embassy to
Jerusalem there's been so many
allegations about him in the past about
Palestine about Muslim and about
settlements also there were allegations
saying that he didn't mind about
settlements you know widening in
Palestine so obviously that's has like a
really bad effect on us the more
settlements the more harder for it is
for us to live so it's like he's aiding
occupation more than half a million
Israelis now live in settlements in the
occupied territories and some of Donald
Trump's advisors are openly partisan his
choice of ambassador to Israel David
Friedman seen here on Israeli television
opposes the two-state solutions
settlement leaders like what they see
in the new administration I think the
people that he's nominating to deal with
the issues regarding this region have
more knowledge are more familiar with
their reality and come with a better
background than what the previous
administration had what will that do on
the policy time will tell the last
Intifada here ended more than a decade
ago but tensions are always swirling
just below the surface and even small
changes to the status quo can provoke a
major uprising
Alex Rossi Sky News in the West Bank